ça fait 11 ans que Francine côté il
travaille comme caissière à
l'Intermarché Boyer à Montréal j'ai pris
ma pré retirer là je pense à ma retraite
mais des fois oui des frais non c'est
pas ça c'est le construire nos
matriculeusement mamie dit se sentir
toujours d'attaque lorsque vient le
temps de servir ses clients même à 68
ans je trouve ça fait du bien ça me fait
du social
ça favora du monde je trouve ça correct
si on est capable de le faire
au Québec les 65 ans et plus sont
maintenant un peu plus nombreux que les
20 ans et moins il représente désormais
20,8% de la population contre 20,6% pour
les jeunes ce qui ne s'était jamais vu
auparavant le poids des personnes âgées
65 et puis va continuer à augmenter mais
de façon beaucoup moins rapide qu'on l'a
observé au cours des récentes années et
va se stabiliser autour de 27 28%. alors
que 6 % des emplois sont actuellement en
vacances au Québec le Conseil du
patronat aimerait que les gouvernements
déploie des mesures fiscales pour
retenir les ennemis sur le marché du
travail l'immigration est une des
solutions et aussi le maintien d'emploi
des travailleurs expérimentés il faut
que les gens puissent continuer à
travailler plus tard pour participer
plus longuement à la vie active 6 % des
75 ans et plus réside présentement au
CHU celd et les besoins iront en
augmentant ce qui fait dire à l'ancien
ministre de la Santé et Jean Hébert
qu’il faut plus d'investissement en
soins à domicile on a une société et des
gouvernements qui ne se sont pas adaptés
à ce vieillissement extrêmement rapide
et qui le doivent le faire de façon
urgente pour que on puisse permettre aux
personnes âgées de participer à la
société permettent aux personnes âgées
de pouvoir vivre à la maison après 2 ans
de pandémie la population du Québec est
revenue à ces élans d'autres fois il y a
connu un bon d'un peu plus de 58 000
habitants en un an ici Gabriel prout
Radio-Canada Montréal